le domaine de la jcch ou du moins ce
qu'il en reste
le vigneron pierre audemar a dû
combattre les flammes dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi dernier
épaulé par les membres de sa famille ils
ont arrosé les bâtiments pour les sauver
mais malgré leurs efforts les pertes
sont énormes on a commencé avec avec
l'instructeur qui est encore par terre
on a commencé à l'éteindre ce qu'on a pu
mais le problème ça prenait les
dimensions impressionnantes sacré mais
petit à petit c'est à dire que les
poutres ont pris feu et les poudres en
transmis aux autres poutres avec
l'isolation du père forme et donc le
chai à barriques à brouiller le che la
cuverie hameau les los ché de
conditionnement biba brûlé puis ensuite
le local de vente et qui a brûlé une
portion de ses 52 hectares de vignes est
également parti en fumée le domaine qui
travaillent les trois couleurs de vin
produit entre 120 et 130 mille
bouteilles par an avec seulement
quelques cuves de rouge restantes les
pertes financières sont lourdes
mais après avoir vécu l'enfer pierre
audemar relativise il est vivant et
déterminés à relancer l'activité avec le
soutien de sa fille film est une de mes
filles et mes une cagnotte en ligne
justement pour éventuellement s'il ya
des personnes qui peuvent nous aider
pour rattraper une partie de ses pertes
dues à la vétusté 500 participants entre
jour je m'y attendais pas je vérité je
n'attendais pas chez vous se qualifier à
penser à ça je me sentis gênés parce que
c'est bon on te
demande et sa muse est nécessaire
on voit ce qu'il faut on est solidaire
salue la famille depuis xvième siècle
elle a connu deux guerres elle a connu
des taux de choses donc on a connu des
inondations en a produit un tas de
choses
c'est pas le moment de
se laisser aller d'autres viticulteurs
ont eux aussi été touchés par l'incendié
tous gardent un objectif en tête être en
mesure de faire les vendanges qui vont
débuter d'ici une dizaine de jours mais
cette année la récolte pourrait avoir un
goût amer pour l'ensemble de la
profession on compte à peu près une
dizaine d'hectares de vignes brûlés ou
saccagés et on compte 2 3 exploitations
qui ont eu des des subi des fortes
pertes et cette année on a subi beaucoup
beaucoup de problèmes on a subi le gel
on a subi la grêle est une année très
difficile pour les vignerons et pour
certains secteurs
certains c'est pas jean coulé aussi donc
il ya eu beaucoup beaucoup de choses
cette année
la récolte sera faible parce que on a
subi une très très forte sécheresse et
c'est pour ça qu'on est arrivé jusqu'à
ses feux
on a une petite récolte
on espère que la qualité sera l'avant il
va falloir qu'on rende sert ses raisins
le plus rapidement possible les pompiers
restent mobilisés en raison des reprises
provoquée par le vent l'incendié a fait
deux morts et détruit sept mille cent
hectares de forêt de vignes et de
garrigue dont près de la moitié de la
réserve nationale naturel de la plaine
des maures